oh you have a fight on the other end
rivers and mo Bamba getting into it
I have no idea what happened but it is
an all-out melee under the basket right
now we had Austin Rivers got some good I
think Papa team Off the Bench to throw
punches at Rivers
[Applause]
that's crazy there will be a number of
objections here
and Baba is still hot
[Applause]
I've never seen that before Tori and
Prince is hot too by the way
[Applause]
Jalen Suggs a takedown of Austin Rivers
that may cost Jalen a ejection there
it might Jeff but yeah if two players
are just
no as a teammate you got to jump in
there I'm just saying what the Fallout
may be following players have been
issuing technical fouls and ejected from
the game
Austin Rivers
Tori and Prince Nick Daniels
Mo Bamba and thugs
[Applause]
Nick even the Minnesota fans are unhappy
with son's Egyptian